hi guys uh it's jerry and
uh i'm gonna i'm in the car
and i'm gonna be doing some traffic
reactions for you guys today
so i'm just about to get on the freeway
you know i figured
i would take you guys along with me and
react to some traffic
right now i'm sitting in a red light
it's kind of [ __ ]
um oh no it's green now all right cool
uh
so i'm hopping on the freeway get on the
101. there's a pedestrian right now
it's got a pretty cool coat on there hey
this song is neat
um a lot of traffic on the on ramps to
the freeway
kind of bummer
all right
all right
yeah the light's not turning at all so i
guess i'm gonna go
all right so now i'm on the freeway it's
pretty sweet
oh cool clouds
all right this land's moving
baby i'm howling for you
baby i'm howling for you
just merge lanes it's pretty cool
all right
well guys the freeway is moving pretty
well so uh
so i guess that's it for my traffic
reaction today sun is shining
it's pretty sick i don't i don't ever
say that
be sick for real uh anyway yeah so i
hope you guys enjoyed and uh
check back next time and uh remember to
subscribe check out all the other videos
on the channel
and uh tune in for more of my reactions
to stuff all right
peace